golfer Tiger Woods is on the men this
morning after withdrawing from the first
tournament of the PGA's FedEx Cup the
Northern Trust which is taking place in
Jersey City New Jersey this weekend
earlier in the week I had a chance to
catch up with woods on the course in an
exclusive conversation for CBS this
morning as we walked the 13th hole we
talked Golf legacy and fatherhood
you know Tigers other job dad to 12-year
old Sam and 10-year old Charlie what's
your favorite thing to do with them just
when you get your moments to be with
them just play you know we just we love
to play we love to go outside and play
no matter what just play you don't just
be around each other whether it's
playing soccer pickleball golf
basketball tennis just a little bit of
competition and yes we're all very
competitive shocking yes egging each
other on snide comments come left and
right non-stop so you offer your dishes
you'd be able to take yeah and if you're
able to take any better addition but
that's one of the neat things about our
sport you can play for so many different
generations you know I was lucky enough
you know jack and I talked about this
you know every now and again that and
when you say Jack Jack Nicklaus
you know Jack and I well he played with
Gene Sarazen in his last PGA I played in
with Jack and his last PGA and while
there is damn near about 80 years of
connectivity there and so that's what's
neat about this game you know I have an
opportunity next year which is even more
crazy to think about if I happen to win
a terma next year that could be like
determined 44 decades some of the shift
in your foundation started after 9/11 no
we were going from city to city
from town to town doing Junior golf
clinics and workshops trying to show
kids there are so many different job
opportunities within golf while 9/11
happened I drove home from st. Louis
where I was and I realized if I was here
right clean up in the background there
now what would the foundation be and so
I wanted to go back to how I was raised
with was family school and then whatever
I was playing and so well school was
number two on the list why is it a head
of golf right now right so let's flip it
so I told my dad we're gonna flip this
thing we're going into a different
direction it's okay give me two weeks
and then all of a sudden we're off and
running and we're in stem and creating
new curriculum all the time and now
we've got over 50 different avenues for
kids and now it's online and there's so
many different things that yeah i what i
do on the golf course had hitting golf
shots and stuff that's one thing and
it's cool it's cool for me it's cool to
watch thank you but it's more cool for
me to put to play but I can tell you
that what the stem program is doing is
changing lives that's some of that
lasting legacy that you leave behind
even without the game ago that will be
Valu I think what we're doing it right
now and stem will be bigger than what
I've done in golf and because it's gonna
be on a global basis already helping
literally millions of kids hopefully
down the road billions of kids and I
just I loved getting a chance to talk
with him obviously about more than golf
that that foundation love that he has is
so strong and there are actual stem labs
that they have Anaheim one place in
Florida they've got a few of them we
mentioned the online courses and a lot
of this is for kids that would not have
access to that type of education as well
there are Earl Woods scholars after his
father he's taken that part so seriously
he knows he has that platform and using
it interesting to hear him talk about
the future and not just winning the next
golf tournament right and and the
tradition the lineage and the
appreciation right and all those years
that's what's crazy and and I think his
appreciation of being back I cannot
express to you how that felt we talked a
lot about that that was in some of the
other interviews stuff that we have air
dance in our pod
that's up right now he's so appreciative
of just being able to play because he
couldn't walk you get that sense
watching memories yeah thank you and
don't forget you can tune in to CBS
today 3:00 Eastern for the Northern
Trust it's the first playoff event of
this season's FedEx Cup right here on
CBS